[Musique]
ben que à partir du moment où on annonce
une
nouvelle même si c'est totalement
objectif et et que en effet ça ça se
réalise il est beaucoup plus pratique de
faire l'autruche
beaucoup beaucoup plus rassurant et
aujourd'hui on vit dans un déni
généralisée avec des gens qui vous
disent mais on va tout va très bien
parce que c'est beaucoup plus facile en
temps parce que c'est beaucoup plus
confortable parce que ça me bouscule pas
les choses et puis jusqu'au jour où ça
va mal se passer parce que ça passera
forcément malheureusement aujourd'hui il
ya pas de sortie sans douleur quand vous
faites une bêtise vous la payer à un
moment ou un autre quand vous allez nous
taper la cloche dans un grand instant et
que vous fait comme un cochon et ben à
la fin on vous amène une édition il faut
la régler et par là c'est exactement
pareil on a vécu à crédit pendant des
années on a on en a largement profité de
la croissance en l'allumant tout allait
très bien et puis maintenant faut
retomber sur terre maintenant faut
régler l'addition alors je dis pas ça je
dis pas que c'est la fin du monde c'est
pas une question de de survie valise ou
quoi que ce soit je dit pas aux gens
qu'il faut s'enterrer dans un moule
guerre avec un pistolet mitrailleur à la
main ça n'a rien à voir avec ça je dis
simplement on a fait un certain nombre
de bêtises qui en plus ont été aggravés
par des actions des banquiers centraux
les autorités économiques et politiques
qui n'ont rien vu venir comme d'habitude
et qui ont géré
la façon la plus la plus plus mauvaises
possibles et que donc il ya un moment où
il va falloir payer l'addition c'est
tout ce que je dis et que l'addition
plus on attend pour la payer plus on
repousse les échéances plus on essaie de
passer à côté
plus on aggrave la chose et donc plus ça
va faire mal c'est tout alors après
c'est un discours que je n'aime pas
entendre parce que ça les dérange parce
que ça les dérange dans la certitude
très souvent
certitude je leur dirai simplement lisez
un tout petit peu regardez ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs et
vous en conclurez que en effet ça peut
pas bien se passer voilà après est ce
qu'il y a est ce qu'il ya des solutions
auxquelles on n'a pas pensé je ne suis
pas certain parce que malheureusement on
est arrivé à un tel point de
non retour et c'est aujourd'hui
général c'est à dire qu'on a pas on n'a
pas la possibilité d'avoir une référence
historique
puisque ça ne s'est pas jamais assez à
ce niveau là
aujourd'hui on navigue un peu à vue la
seule chose dont on est sûr
c'est que ça ne peut pas se régler sans
douleur voilà alors après que ça ne
plaise pas que les gens qui pensent que
jean profil teixeira
salle et ça les regarde souvent leur
argumentation est assez pauvre
voilà moi j'ai jeu quand je dis je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas l'ange grand chose à
vendre je dis simplement et un certain
nombre de choses il faut être factuel
faux moi je suis prêt à apporter tous
les chiffres qui prouvent ce que je dis
j'ai pas de souci avec ça il faut être
factuel et quand il ya des choses qui
mathématiquement
ne peuvent pas
revenir en arrière sans s'en être soldés
auparavant et donc vous êtes
malheureusement obligés de
prévoir certaines choses et certaines
choses qui n'ont pas être forcément
drôle
la planche alliés normalement vous aviez
la création monétaire qui étaient
corrélées si vous voulez à la
croissance
mondiale d'accord la croissance du
commerce extérieur dont elle a besoin
évidemment de
créer de la monnaie
alors créer de la monnaie s'est pas créé
des billets et ses créances et c'est
tout un tas de choses c'est pas
simplement des billets papier donc
normalement vous aviez une croissance
mondiale qui étaient autour de 3,4 et
que vous aviez une croissance de la de
la masse monétaire mondiale qui était
aussi de trois quarts a dit ce qui était
normal
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une situation
où vous avez une croissance mondiale qui
est plutôt proche de zéro et vous avez
une croissance
de la de la masse monétaire qui est
plutôt autour de 17 18% quoiqu'il ya
déjà un décalage qui collent plus si
vous avez quelque chose qui n'est plus
basée sur rien
de la monnaie papier c'est quoi ces je
vous prends une feuille de papier je
vous marque chiffres dessus si vous avez
confiance en moi je vous ai marqué 100
euros ça vaut 100 euros si le gars en
face va me vend des marchandises et qui
croient dans ce billet qu'il a confiance
dans celui qui l'émet ça vaut 100 euros
jour il n'a plus confiance ça vaut quoi
ça vous et bon d'accord ça vaut zéro
parce que ça vaut à peine près du papier
si votre monnaie mais plus basé sur rien
session lors elle est plus basé sur rien
et sur la croissance et sur l'a10 d'un
pays qu'est ce que ça vaut rien le jour
où les gens perdent confiance le jour où
je vous tend un billet ou me dit ah mais
non mais ça vaut rien ton truc je ne
peux pas le prendre à ce moment là il
vaut zéro et
c'est exactement comme si demain vous
prenez tous les billets de l'autre jeu
de monopoly
c'est pareil y'a un chiffre qui est
marqué dessus d'accord vous sortez vous
essayez de vous acheter une voiture avec
seal type qui en face de vous n'est pas
un crétin peut pas il va vous dire
monsieur ce sont des billets de monopoly
savons rien ce dont ils ne seront pas
content c'est qu'aujourd'hui la la les
billets en dollars en lienne et en euros
sont des billets de monopoly
donc ça ne tient que jusqu'au jour où un
pays ou un intervenant économique dit
moi je reconnais pas se plier comme
ayant une valeur
200 500 2 50 euros moi je dis qu'il ya
pas de valeur à partir de ce moment-là
ça s'écroule donc ce système c'était
voltaire qui disait ça
au 18e
1729 croit la phrase de voltaire
là-dessus qui dit 1 une monnaie basée
sur la confiance
envers celui qui l'émet donc ses skis
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
est le cas
retournera invariablement à sa valeur
d'origine les héros donc
aujourd'hui on a encore confiance pour
combien de temps j'en sais rien mais il
ya un moment à force de créer quelque
chose de rien et pas forcément vous
casser la figure pourquoi est-ce que
cicéron ou le voit bien avec ce fameux
jeu de monopoly c'est intéressant comme
comme parler parce que
si le banquier
vous redonne des sous
vous n'arrêtez jamais je ne par
définition si à chaque fois que vous
avez besoin de vous re cave et le le
banquier vous donne des sous le jeune
monopoly ne s'arrête jamais
donc sur les met sur les matières
premières ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que aujourd'hui
les politiques non et monétaires sont
responsables d'une bonne partie de la
hausse des matières premières
notamment alimentaires c'est à dire que
les ce qu'on a les printemps arabes
sont pas venu comme ça le printemps
arabe c'est pas tout d'un coup des
populations qui se sont aperçus que
c'était dirigé par départ des dictatures
ça faisait 40 ans qu'ils étaient dirigés
par des dictatures ils sont pareils et
tous ensemble le même jour donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que en grande
partie d'ailleurs si vous regardez où ça
a commencé ça a commencé souvent dans le
sud du pays et c'est des gens qui
n'avaient pas bouffer et pourquoi il est
bien allé bouffer tout simplement parce
que le prix les prix des matières
premières alimentaires avaient explosé
mais pourquoi il avait explosé et ça
c'est intéressant c'est parce que
monsieur vernon qui était
il suffit de regarder le nombre de
contrats futurs sur les matières
premières pour s'apercevoir que c'est en
grande partie en très grande partie dû à
la politique de monsieur bernanke quand
il a annoncé son premier quantitative
easing les le nombre des contrats
futures sur
matières premières a été multiplié par
mille et sur le deuxième que ça a été
multiplié par dix mille alors moi je
veux bien que monsieur bernanke nous
disent que il est absolument pas
responsables de la hausse des matières
premières mais enfin quand même il ya
une curieuse coïncidence si on peut
appeler ça une coïncidence voilà donc
c'est vraiment une il ya eu il ya
vraiment une liaison entre cette
politique
monétaire et le la hausse des matières
premières et aussi la hausse du prix du
pétrole donc de l'énergie donc
il faudrait que ce monsieur arrête ces
quantitative easing parce que ça va nous
mener tranquillement à notre perte à
tous
[Musique]
les retraites bat les retraites
sympa je crois que c'est clair les
retraites enfin ça fait longtemps qu'on
le sait
c'est pas c'est pas une surprise
il y en aura pas mais ici s'il y avait
quatre ep qui a été touchée ça serait ça
serait encore
ça serait encore bien mais
malheureusement tout le monde va
trinquer
pourquoi tout le monde va trinquer bas
parce qu'il ya un moment où
malheureusement vous ne pouvez plus vous
permettre de payer des retraites par par
répartition parce que vous avez plus de
gens à la retraite que de gens qui
travaillent donc l'équation aller assez
vite fait
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
malheureusement le système des retraites
il sautera savait qu'en plus on avait
fait 1 on avait fait un petit fond de de
complément pour payer les retraites
il a été bien investie par des gens
par l'élite de notre société il a été
bien investit sur des actions
et évidemment ses actions en 2008 elles
ont pris un coup derrière la tête en
2011 elles ont repris un coup derrière
la tête et on n'est pas prêt de revoir
les cours donc on a commencé par perdre
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus je suis pas
certain que ils servent à quoi que ce
soit ce fonds donc voilà vous êtes
aujourd'hui toute façon mais pas
simplement je vous dis les retraités
tous les épargnants ou en trinquet quand
pourquoi pourquoi on vous a remonté le
le taux du livret a c'est pas pour c'est
pas pour vous donner de l'argent c'est
pas pour vous donner 1 75% d'intérêt
c'est simplement parce que ça permet à
l'état nationalisé les parents alors ils
ont nationalisé les pins les français
qui sont toujours contents
qu'on s'occupe d'eux se sont précipités
dans le livret a est pourquoi on a fait
ça tout simplement parce qu'en 2013
figurez vous que c'est la france qui
sera le plus gros
émetteur de dette d'europe et qu' il
fallait bien trouver quelqu'un pour
acheter ces foutus sauter et donc les
hobbits d'état et que bah ça y est on a
trouvé on a trouvé le pichon parfait
c'est celui qui est allé dans un livret
a et puis à un moment ou un autre
je vous dis soit par le biais d'un
défaut de paiement soit par le biais de
d'hyper inflation qui voit il vaudra 0
voilà merci circulez ya rien à voir
c'est une équation qui mathématiquement
est compliquée à résoudre non mais
problème c'est que c'est que vous êtes
allé trop loin on a dépassé le point de
vente où donc il ya un moment si vous
voulez quoi vous fassiez que je vous
laisse y ait fuit les
méthodes américaines d'accord les
américains ont décidé que il était
absolument pas question de faire le
moindre effort et donc
il laisse filer et puis va être wallon
vers annoncent qu'ils disent qu'ils
arrivent
les japonais paraît même même politique
en europe je vous ai dit les allemands
sont terrorisés parce que ils savent ce
qui va se passer et donc ils n'ont pas
envie de revivre ça
mais en attendant on a choisi donc pour
l'instant
une autre voie qui est de dire on va
faire des économies mais le problème
c'est que les gens ont oublié c'est que
aujourd'hui
et hier aussi c'était pareil
qui est-ce qui avait pris le relais qui
est ce qui faisait la croissance dont
c'était les dépenses de l'état c'était
des salaires qui était versée par l'état
c'était pas le privé qui finalement
apporter de la croissance donc c'était
en grande partie l'état et ben quand
l'état un peu plus quand l'état n'a plus
d'argent
et bah c'est fini que vous n'avez plus
de croissance alors aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qui se passe vous avez l'état qui n'a
plus d'argent et qui dit bon bah on va
on va faire des
économies j'ai pas tellement d'ailleurs
des économies qui fait c'est c'est une
ponction fonctionne un tout petit peu
plus donc ils fonctionnent les retraites
il fonctionnait salaire il fonctionne
mais bon tout oui mais le problème c'est
que c'est trop tard
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ces politiques là
sont évidemment à ces sionistes puisque
si vous aussi vous diviser par deux les
salaires faut pas imaginer les gens nous
rend ce mais comme des fous donc c'est
évidemment des politiques récessionniste
quand vous avez la cession à une
récession votre coût de la dette il est
à chez pas à 5%
aujourd'hui en espagne les espagnols
sont d'été si vous comptez le
l'endettement sur l'immobilier vous êtes
à largement plus de 100 %
donc ça veut dire que ça vous coûte au
moins 5% si vous faites pas 5% de
croissance du pib vous pouvez pas payer
les intérêts on est bien d'accord donc
c'est très simple
aujourd'hui personne est en mesure de
payer les intérêts la dette ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que tout le monde en
30 mois après mois pour payer les
intérêts de la dette donc vedette elle
augmente et quand vous avez un pib qui
est vraiment négatif mais ben il faut en
plus emprunter pour
pour piller et budget etc ça ça veut
dire que à un moment votre dette
continue à augmenter qu'est ce qui va se
passer les marchés vont commencer à se
poser des questions sur le remboursement
possible ou pas possible de cette dette
est à partir d'un certain moment les
marchés se dissout là je vais pas me
faire rembourser donc le le le le coût
du du
les taux d'intérêt c'est quoi c'est le
sait le le prix qu'on demande pour
justement paraît ce risque de non
remboursement
donc ce prix ses taux d'intérêt à ce
moment là ils seraient pas exposés et
donc c'est de plus en plus difficile de
payer les intérêts et donc ça y est
c'est plié vous êtes rentré dans un
espèce de certes infernale qui fait que
c'est le serpent qui se mord la queue
pouvait faire autant d'économies vous
voulez si vous faites des économies ça
pèse sur le pib si le pib négatif à ce
moment là vous pouvez pas payer les
intérêts de la dette et vous ne pouvez
pas rembourser votre dette et donc votre
dette elle continue à augmenter année
après année
exterminer le alors vous avez des gens
qui ont des qui ont des solutions très
simpliste nous disent bas il ya ka pas
rembourser le fameux yaka il ya qu'à
faut qu'on
donc
si on pour se part oui d'accord donc
tous les épargnants son aîné 6 les gens
font pas le calcul ils disent oui mais
toute façon il ya des riches n'y a pas
des riches le livret a c'est le départ
et c'est pas que des riches dedans tous
les tous les produits que vous avez
bancaires cédées par lé dakor et cette
épargne à les placer sur quoi sur les
oblige s'il voulait rembourser pas eh
ben c'est terminé vous n'avez plus n'est
pas donc il faut arrêter de sortir des
solutions comme ça
kiki qui n'en sont pas vous entendez les
gens qui disent avec toute façon
la bce n'a elle n'a qu'un maîtres ddo
mixant taux d'intérêt
ami qui m'a les acheter
et puis à côté de ça vous avez le même
le la même personne qui vous dit à bas
toute façon c'est très simple il ya ka
pas payer de taux d'intérêt qui vous dit
et il est grand de mouvaux placement
c'est quoi
il ya un rendement dans un placement
c'est bien bien taux d'intérêt quelque
part
[Musique]
c'est un terrain de bêtises c'est comme
ça
les agences de notation
on s'en fiche
c'est terrifiant les agences de notation
ça me semble fait ça fait quand même
mares et que vous avez quand même des
gens des banquiers
qui paye les agences de notation pour
savoir quoi penser
ou s'il pouvait pas le faire eux mêmes
pensées et
ils vous avaient des agences de notation
qui leur disent quoi penser souvent avec
trois trains de retard insert que moi
j'ai pas attendu
j'ai pas attendu que
standard and poor c'est nous disent me
disent que la grèce ne sera pas pour
savoir que la grèce ne remboursera
jamais et je trouve triste que des
banquiers et
les autorités
économiques
est attendue que ce temps à une course
leur dise quoi penser sur sur la grèce
donc j'estime que ça sert pas à grand
chose
sauf peut-être à donner des salaires
mirobolants à quelques analystes qui
sinon aurait pas de métier mais c'est
tout ça n'a aucun intérêt mais je
aujourd'hui j'achète tous les jours des
hobbies corporate j'ai pas besoin de
savoir quelle est la notation standard &
poor saône ou 10 pour savoir que si
j'achète une une obligation lafarge à
deux ans lafarge va me rembourser
c'est une certitude j'ai pas besoin de
savoir sa note je m'en fiche
complètement donc
je dirais apprenez à penser par lui-même
cela vous évitera d'être suspendu à la
note de standard poor's ou moody's faut
quand même ce bien se rendre compte que
aujourd'hui des pays dont on sait
pertinemment
qu'ils ne rembourseront jamais leurs
dettes comme le japon sont toujours
notée double awa - ouf peu importe c'est
à dire en gros si vous voulez surtout
jour de teddy 701
sale dans l'échelle des notes des
agences de notation c'est juste
grotesque alors qu'on sait qu'ils
renonceront pas donc faut arrêter il ya
un moment où
franchement enfin apprenez à réfléchir
par eux-mêmes ça ça sera beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus intéressant après
alors maintenant
elle se fout elles se font sanctionner
par
par les états unis que ça déplaît
souvent à demande de se faire de cette
fait dégradé
par an continuent dans leur continue
dans le ridicule
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'état américain pourrait
être content il n'est pas encore à
triple cd donc le doigt en compte en
plus tôt et
il faut arrêter valse ce cirque avec
avec les
chances de natation ils ont échoué
complètement enfin on l'a vu avec les
sopranes tous les produits subprime
étaient notés triple a comme on voit que
c'est n'importe quoi ça va venir
c'est là c'est l'impunité de toute façon
tous les politiques vous allez pas vous
allez pas mettre monsieur bernanke en
prison alors qu'il le mettrait m est
cent fois parce qu'il est en train de
poulets et son pays et l'économie
mondiale sauf que il n'ya jamais en
prison
vous n'avez jamais aucun banquier qui a
subi quoi que ce soit comme sanction
vous n'aurez pas non plus les banquiers
du fsf qui subiront des sanctions mais
c'est pas c'est pas étonnant si on en
est là aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il
n'ya jamais de sanctions qu'est-ce que
jamais personne n'est responsable de
quoi que ce soit donc à partir de ce
moment là je vois pas pourquoi les gens
continueraient pas aujourd'hui vous avez
vu un banquier qui s'est retrouvé lanto
parce qu'ils avaient perdu des biens
vous avez vu un banquier qui s'est
retrouvé en taule avec le scandale du
libor n'ont jamais donc comme les loups
qui s'arrête aujourd'hui vous voyez quoi
vous avez vous avez une alerte quand
même monstrueux en 2008 on a fait tout
sauter avec les avec les bêtises des
manques et on aurait pu se dire bon dans
un monde à peu près normale
ces gens là ils ont quand même très très
chaud aux fesses
ils vont essayer de les en plus ils vont
essayer de de prendre moins de risques
et c'est pas du tout pas du tout vous
regardez les bilans des banques
pour la plupart ils ont augmenté
la bnp nous dit que son sont ils ont ils
ont bien baissé leurs bilans ouais ils
ont baissé de il avait un bilan qui
était au dessus de 1000 milliards et
maintenant il est à 1930 je crois gros
gros effort gros efforts et qui pendant
ce temps là les positions à terme
donc hors bilan de la bnp sont passées
de 46 milliards à 48,8 milliards
d'euros franchement je vois que je vois
je vois pas moi j'ai quand même du mal à
avoir une diminution du risque de temps
ou alors peut-être qu'on va essayé de
m'expliquer dire qu'ils apprirent xts
mais j'ai du mal on voit la plus vieille
banque italienne est une des plus
vieilles banques du monde monte paschi
qui a fait faillite la semaine dernière
où la semaine d'avant je ne sais plus
parce que on a découvert tout d'un coup
que à elle c'était pas si bien ça qu'il
y avait des cds dans tous les sens et
qu'elle allait sauter alors qu'on vienne
pas nous raconter aujourd'hui que le
risque a diminué que les banques
maintenant maîtrise les choses externe
ou tri sur un du tout et il le risque il
a absolument pas diminué
aujourd'hui je vous dis a pas de y'a pas
de il n'y a pas de régulation
dans les banques y a pas plus de
contrôles qu'avant il n'y a pas plus de
vouge est de l'inde de la poudre aux
yeux en me disant ça y est maintenant on
a organisé des choses et cetera on vous
parle beaucoup de bâle iii parce que ça
va mettre un petit peu plus de 2 un
petit peu plus de fonds propres le
problème c'est pas c'est pas m 1 2% de
de fonds propres supplémentaires quand
on voit les positions nous et 10 cas on
tue mia c'est pas parce que vous allez
rajouter 1 % +2 ratio tiers one que ça
va ça va sauver les choses et il est
tout le reste découle de ça aussi c'est
à dire qu'il ya absolument aucun
contrôle du malade pourquoi parce que
quand on veut organiser les choses quand
on veut essayer de maîtriser les choses
va voir les banquiers en 2008 qui sont
en train de se noyer on leur tend une
feuille blanche on leur demande de
signer non s'occupe de mettre les choses
en place derrière qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on n'a pas fait ça du tout on les a
sortis de l'eau on les a séché on leur a
donné du pognon gratuit en leur disant
continuer à jouer avec d'accord dont les
arts ont plumé et après on leur dit
écoutez les bien si ça vous dérange pas
trop est-ce qu'on pourrait s'organiser
pour faire une séparation entre les
activités dans quai les activités marché
puisqu'ils nous répond le banquier il
faut répondre va te faire voir voilà
avec un grand sourire en disant en plus
si tu m'embête je ne prête plus à
l'économie très pas toutes façons mais
il l'a fait croire aux autorités
politiques qui dira non mon dieu non non
non non pas ça s'il vous plaît continuez
à prêter à l'économie
ok bon alors tu remballe ta ta loi qu'on
l'a et puis nous continuer à faire bien
tranquille voilà c'est comme ça que ça
se passe et donc vous n'avez absolument
aucune loi aujourd'hui qui soit une
vraie loi qui organise les choses et qui
en effet fasse en sorte d'éviter que les
choses comme 2008 se reproduise parce
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont parfaitement
capables de se reproduire et de se
reproduire de façon plus bas
sur les paradis fiscaux je dirais
c'est un c1 c'est un faux problème on
agite on agite la suisse
[Musique]
mon peuple
et puis pendant ce temps là le devient
were ça continue les îles
anglo-normandes ça continue en compte
que ça continue et cetera et cetera donc
chacun à son son son petit son petit
paradis fiscal et puis de l'autre côté
vous avez les français les allemands
fallait européens qui disent ah bah
suisse c'est pas bien et puis pendant ce
temps là on continue avec les relents
violence est pas un paradis fiscal peut
être l'irlande avec douze ennemis %
d'impôt sur les sur les entreprises
c'est pas un paradis fiscal ça mais on
continue avec l'irlande et et de l'autre
côté
on tape sur les quinze clampins qui ont
les quinze clampins qui ont qui ont un
compte dans un dans un paradis fiscal
comme la suisse ou en dehors
bien sait pas c'est pas le problème les
gros montants les gros les gros
les gros comptes des entreprises
extérieures ils sont pas ils sont pas en
suisse y sont ils sont ailleurs donc
et on les y afférent très en plus en
mettant en mettant l'irlande en europe
donc face et c'est juste grotesque comme
d'habitude mais oh ça fait ça fait un
chiffon rouge de plus qu'on agit de
mener pour vous pensiez à autre chose
quoi
[Musique]
passer de ces mettre un doute sur tout
ce qui surtout ce qui est consensuelle
et surtout ce qui sur tout ce qui sort
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui faut pas
prendre les chiffres tels qu'ils et
elles qui tombe faut pas prendre les
idées telles qu'elles tombent il faut
essayer de les confronter deux de
l'echange et de regarder si c'est
cohérent incohérent et c'est aujourd'hui
c'est un boulot qui n'est absolument pas
fait vous avez dans des salles de
trading des traders qui attendent le
chiffre de l'emploi ces lieux prévus où
c'est moins bon prévu et puis
il décide une stratégie vis-à-vis de ça
jamais à aucun moment ils vont essayer
de regarder si ce chiffre est cohérent
avec les autres de mes gonds pleuvoir
alors vous avez des données économiques
aujourd'hui que vous n'avez pas c'est à
dire que essayer de trouver les vrais
chiffres du chômage en europe je vous
souhaite bien du plaisir
en revanche vous avez des pays qui
publie qui publie vraiment donc aux
états unis publient même si vous donne
un chiffre qui est traficoter de bon il
suffit de dalles et de travailler ou pas
il suffit d'aller chercher il suffit
d'aller regarder il suffit de essayer de
réfléchir un tout petit peu
et vous pouvez à ce moment-là retrouver
les vrais chiffres donc c'est pas très
compliqué
vous pouvez aussi essayer quand on vous
sort
un chiffre de de croissance par exemple
en chine il est très difficile d'avoir
des statistiques mais vous pouvez
essayer de réfléchir un tout petit peu
vous regardez le chiffre de cet ennemi
qui sort et puis vous dit tiens c'est
amusant parce que le baltic dry index
qui est qui et le prix des des du
freight
entre justement entre la chine et
l'occident par navire
il est curieusement au plus bas c'est
amusant donc si jamais la croissance
reparte s et on aurait besoin de bateaux
pour exporter là c'est pas de bol c'est
au plus bas puis vous regardez le
chiffre du du commerce extérieur chinois
et puis vous regardez le chiffre des
importations américaines qui vous voyez
que juste ça correspond pas c'est
amusant donc on en a un qui ment dans
l'histoire c'est qui ces états unis
c'est les chinois ou les deux
probablement les deux
vous avez tout un tas de choses comme ça
on a regardé on a regardé aussi les
consommations électriques 1
ils essaient de nous faire avaler qui
font cet ennemi % croissance et puis il
n'ya pas n'y a pas de consommation
supérieure de l'électricité donc il ya
un truc qui colle pas
on a on a tout un tas de femmes à toute
une batterie comme ça de 2,2
de corrélation à établir et il faut il
faut essayer de
d'être cohérent il faut essayer de
trouver
si on nous raconte des balivernes aussi
réellement il ya un support
réel à ces chiffres là donc aujourd'hui
on sait très bien moi même type ma
petite maroc parce que ça m'amuse tout
le temps tellement c'est gros et
tellement sais c'est mal fait c'est le
chômage américain le chômage américain
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qui fait
diminuer la population active et que
c'est le
la baisse du taux de chômage et est
uniquement dû à ça pas autre chose donc
il ya vraiment c est là c'est purement
du bon sens aussi c'est pas il suivit
suffit pas de sortir d'une grande école
il faut simplement avoir un chouïa de
bon sens on vous dit les états unis ray
industrialise 1 c'est-à-dire refont ou
revenir des industries chez eux et
recommença
[Musique]
à ne plus faire que du service mais
faire de l'industrie et puis vous
regardez le nombre de bons hommes qui
sont qui sont engagés dans l'industrie y
en a pas débauche moi je veux bien qu'on
réindustrialiser meilleur je pense que
il ya un moment où il va bien falloir
qu'ils engagent des gens pareils sur le
logement on vous dit le logement est
repartie aux états unis ah oui c'est
marrant il engage personnes ils font
comment pour les construire les maisons
ils se construisent tout ce bon ou alors
c'est des maisons en kit et ccc les
clients qui les construisent bon donc
yaya il ya un vrai aujourd'hui il ya des
vrais
une vraie réflexion à avoir sur les
chiffres qu'on communique on sait très
bien sûr les chiffres d'inflation vous
balade je veux dire tout le monde fait
ses courses tout le monde sait que
l'inflation elle est par un emmy en
france bon donc c'est pas très compliqué
ça donc il faut une il faut avoir un
tout petit peu de bon sens et il faut
avoir un tout petit peu de réflexion
c'est vrai il faut travailler c'est pas
facile tous les jours mais il ya des
bureaux d'études ou il ya 300 personnes
et les gars ils nous sortent des
énormités en permanence qui les fasse un
peu bosser les 300 bus
[Musique]